hallo mein name ist willkommen mit
morgen becken angebracht bei einer der
schlimmsten momente meines lebens wir
befinden uns heute hier in und ich hatte
ja letztes schon mal einige spiele
gemacht und da wurde mir gesagt man kann
hier auf party klicken und dann kann ich
eine party erstellen wo ihr mir nach
sonnen könnt und wir zusammen spielen
können
super deswegen habe ich jetzt einfach
mal so eine party erstellt und werde
jetzt einfach mal auf twitter einen
tweet verfassen kommt alle algerien
spielen dann den link und füttert luca
rio so dass die mich dann alle füttern
sollen weil ich versuchen dadurch einen
rekord aufzustellen sei vielleicht zu
hoch gegriffen weil ich das definitiv
nicht hinkriegen werde okay sind jetzt
drei sekunden seitdem tut vergangenen
sechs retweets und 59 und es kommen
schon die ersten wahrscheinlich jetzt
gleich auf den server des herstellers
gäste und laufen jetzt mal ein bisschen
rum ich finde agrarius zurzeit einfach
dazu das beste spiel was es gibt
neben nintendogs und gott simulator und
minecraft und minecraft remote also gta
es auch eigentlich noch ganz toll
gemacht hat echt unglaublich spaß mein
gott es fängt schon leicht anzulegen ich
glaube jetzt nicht eine aufnahme weil
die aufnahmen über 30 fps es aber ich
glaube es gerade schon die ersten bau
soll damit den rassen gegessen ich hoffe
bauern ein
das hat er da von der pizza ich glaube
auf diesem server sind auch noch einige
andere leute das sieht nicht so aus als
wäre das einen klaren der hier gerade
spiegelt
das ist doch nicht wahr jetzt wurde ich
gefressen man okay ich bin schon wieder
ein bisschen größer weiß gerade von ein
paar netten menschen hier gefüttert
wurde ich möchte nur die top ten
freundin ich möchte nur die domain
gottes fängt schon an zu ruckeln ich
habe mir gedacht dass es vielleicht ein
ganz gute idee war es letztendlich
glaube ich nicht oder name hallo
gegessen dienstes conradi da kommen die
einzigen leute die ich bisher auf diesem
server gesehen habe hießen contractor
gay und luca stinkt nach kot
das war super lieb von euch handel
communitys sind zu jung wir scheinen
demnach wir helfen ich werde hier wieder
nur gefressen man man das ist doch nicht
war kann man nicht einen eigenen server
machen irgendwie ich schaffe nicht nur
mit eurer hilfe irgendwie die top ten
aber ich war einmal leicht ab 1 das
video verlinkt ich euch mal das analoge
fressen dann fresse ich habe den ganzen
anderen kleinen chance eben mano es auch
es kann dich sein kann auf meinem
bildschirm gerotzt hat sich mich
aufgeregt habe auch einmal ein gemälde
mit gemessen immer einmal hier hallo ich
danke ich glaube der server stützt
gerade ab ich denke
ja ihr habt den server gecrasht diese
website ist nicht verfügbar
gut gemacht freunde ihr habt wohl gerade
wirklich agrio gecrasht aber dann spiele
ich halt eben schnell dieses browsergame
es irgendwie addario wieder da ist
es macht super viel spaß hier gerade
kummer ich bin sogar schon bei scor
nummer tot was kannst du hallo ich habe
gerade eine halbe stunde gewartet und
jetzt versuchen wir es wieder ich gebe
als nick luca rio ein ich habe hier eine
neue party gerade eben erstellt und die
spielen als gessen ich habe wieder ein
gesagt dass sie mich füttern sondern ich
glaube ich bin gerade gestorben anhand
des leaderboards kann man glaube ich
sehen dass wir wieder mit einem klaren
auf diesem server sind
was soll das hab ich jetzt einfach mal
dass bitte damit ich hier schnell den
ganzen schritt fressen kann und von euch
ist noch niemand da oh mein gott mein
alter das ist nicht wahr
oh mein gott wir haben irgendwie gleiche
größe ich weiß nicht wollen dass dieser
disput andere alt ist wir sind die man
mit diesen scheiß spanien hier auf dem
server und es ist nichts man ich habe
mir gedacht wenn ich mit euch zocke dann
kommen wir alle zusammen auf einen
server und ihr könnt mich schön füttern
und dann sind wir
ich will nicht mehr
da hatte man von mir kommt fitter mich
ja ja ja fügt an ich hab mir du nur du
musst nicht retten du musst mich
verstellt
oh mein gott ist riesig da rechts
raffael vötter mich fit hat mich fit hat
mich alle hier ich brauche hessen bitte
helft mir freunde da edu den kann ich
essen hier da orange und den fress ich
noch und jetzt ihr euch auch da hilft
luca hilft mir hilft mir helft mir doch
da ja da kommt noch mehr noch mehr
helfen mir helfen ich fühle mich wie so
ein kleiner knirps umgeben von riesigen
andrang von riesigen anderen leuten wie
einfach alle viel grösser sind als ich
gibt es nicht eine möglichkeit es sich
alleine mit euch auf einem server kann
und nicht irgendwie das so komische
leute mit solchen kurzen namen damit
spielen bacon für luca ja okay und
aufwärts geht mir dort oben fresse ich
glaube dass schon so trotzdem kann ich
aufpassen da und kollegen kommen den
fress ich auch jetzt von echte ganze
zeit trotz guck mal hier zack zack hier
den fress ich noch von ihr vorne müssen
wir auch wieder hier diese andreas teile
das snowboard star luca hier will ich
ich bin hier ja danke dass auch vida
loca rio hier hilft mir auch dass ein
fake
das kann nicht sein solche effekte nicht
zu wissen endlich zusammen kommen hilft
mir ja mal kommt prompt kommt comcom
nein nein nein nein nein nein wir müssen
mein gott okay ich bin einer der bibel
warum